bonjour à tous bienvenue c'est l'ère de
parlement hebdo 45 minutes pour faire le
tour de l'actualité politique et
parlementaire mais côté ktm ou son
tombereau jours à tous vas si les titres
donc de notre émission le projet de
réforme de la constitution voulue par le
président habib sy qui vise à inscrire
l'état d'urgence et la déchéance de
nationalité est enfin entrer cette
semaine dans l'arène de l'assemblée
nationale sous la pression des députés
ps
le gouvernement a dû consentir à une
nouvelle version du texte et au même
moment le sénat examiner cette semaine
une proposition de loi pour lutter
contre le terrorisme elle vise à étendre
l'arsenal sécuritaire non seulement
contre le terrorisme mais aussi contre
des délits de droit commun y compris sur
internet
enfin c'est une loi qui est inscrite à
l'ordre du jour du parlement depuis 2013
texte qui vise à renforcer les moyens
contre la prostitution et sanctionner
les clients
elle continue son très très long
parcours votée en troisième lecture
elle doit à présent aujourd'hui devant
les sénateurs et nous accueillons cette
semaine yannick jadot bonjour vous êtes
député européen europe écologie les
verts aux est l'un des initiateurs avec
d'autres de l'appel pour une primaire de
gauche on y reviendra tout à l'heure que
longuement mais on va commencer par des
rôles actualités si vous voulez bien
chargé de la semaine on commence à lundi
et on reparle des indemnisations chômage
al'approche des négociations sur
l'assurance chômage la tension monte la
ministre de travail n'exclut aucune
piste y compris celle d'une dégressivité
des allocations explications faustine
saint-geniès c'est la nouvelle piste du
gouvernement pour favoriser le retour à
l'emploi est allégé les comptes de
l'assurance chômage
la dégressivité concrètement cela
revient à baisser les allocations
chômage à partir d'une certaine durée de
prise en charge par pôle emploi
une piste évoquée hier par la ministre
du travail
le gouvernement prendra ses
responsabilités et évoquera toutes les
pistes y compris avec une notion de
dégressivité la dégressivité avaient été
mises en oeuvre
je crois de 90 à 2000 2001 elle n'a pas
montré
d'après les études que sur les personnes
qui étaient les plus en difficulté que
savent jouer un rôle
il faut regarder les choses de façon non
passionnée dès ce matin le ministre des
finances lui emboîte le pas mais en
proposant des garanties pour les
chômeurs c'est une piste qui doit
s'accompagner d'autres
si vous êtes dans la dégressivité d'un
côté vous devez être c'est ce que disait
très bien le président la république
dans l'augmentation des droits à la
formation des droits la reprise de
l'emploi
autant de déclarations qui sont un
sérieux appel du pied aux partenaires
sociaux qui doivent négocier la nouvelle
convention d'assurance chômage d'ici
mars prochain dans un contexte critique
le taux de chômage atteint 10,6 pour
cent de la population active et la dette
de l'unedic explose à 29 milliards
d'euros d'ici la fin 2016
une équation insoluble alors que la
france connaît l'une des plus longues
périodes d'indemnisation en europe avec
24 mois sans dégressivité et 36 mois
pour les plus de 50 ans un acquis du
modèle social français que le
gouvernement semble plus que jamais
décidé à écorner ya déjà deux ans que
c'est le bon moment pour vous de ceux de
toucher à cette à quai et modèle social
français en panne de fort chômage
non non moi je suis très favorable aux
modèles de flex sécurité c'est de dire
on flexibilise le modèle nordique ont
flexibilise le marché du travail parce
que c'est vrai que
fond le code du travail le financement
de tous les systèmes sociaux ont été
construits à une époque où font rentrer
dans une entreprise de production
on avait un cdi de 40 ans et on en
sortait pour la retraite
maintenant les gens bougent dans tous
les sens tout ça donc il faut
flexibiliser tout ça mais si en même
temps qu'on demande à tout le monde
d'être plus flexible et tout le monde
sait qu'il faut bouger mais si on leur
demande d'être plus flexible et qu'en
même temps on les uns sécurisé du point
de vue de leurs droits eh ben on fait on
fait on fait tout et son contraire
ouais soit si on veut flexibiliser si on
veut de la flexicurité c'est oui la
flexibilité mais plus de sécurité et
laure même inspiré de ce qui se passe
ailleurs chez ses voisins oui mais c'est
un peu ça veut dire que vous pouvez pas
ne pouvait pas être demandée à donner
des droits des entreprises au fond pour
licencier plus facilement et renier ou
attaquer les droits des salariés
quand ils sont licenciés ça ça marchera
pas sarah renferme tout le monde ça fait
se replier tout le monde et on n'arrive
pas à bouger
c'est pas la première fois qu'on utilise
cet artifice si on peut dire même dans
les années 90 on l'a déjà utilisé est-ce
que selon vous c'est quoi c'est un choix
de la politique
un choix de manuel valls sur la ligne
politique
je crois qu'aujourd'hui au fond ce
gouvernement joue aussi étonnamment en
permanence d'une forme de subversion de
dire on est un gouvernement élu comme un
gouvernement de gauche et au fond de
subversion c'est en permanence
d'attaquer le corpus de valeurs de
principes de gauche c'est ça la ligne de
manuel vals je crois qu'aujourd'hui
c'est ça d'ailleurs il l'avait exprimé
vous souvenez quand il est dit il y en a
marre de tous ces socialistes de tous
ces zombies et gorriti de vieille gauche
qui défendent des valeurs et au fond on
a l'impression que c'est cette
subversion permanente mais elle
s'adresse à qui cette subversion
perdante moi je suis prêt à les attaquer
les corporatismes les conservatismes qui
a dans la société incontestablement plus
empêche d'évoluer
le problème c'est qu'ils attaquent
toujours les mêmes conservatisme je n'ai
pas vu sur cette question des indemnités
j'ai pas vu ni emmanuel macron ni manuel
valls dire tiens on va peut-être y
compris par la loi si c'est nécessaire
réduire l'écart de salaire entre
l'échelle des salaires dans les
entreprises qui a complètement explosé
ces dernières années
je n'ai pas vu manuel valls emmanuel
macron dire on va toucher aux golden
parachute ne savez c'est toutes ces
choses là on dit là le medef va faire
des des chartes du volontaire mais dès
que ce sont les salariés
là on passe par la loi et on tape et je
trouve ça totalement déséquilibrée donc
au fond ils veulent pas faire bouger
l'ensemble de la société
ils veulent en permanence être subversif
mais plutôt sur les acquis sur les
valeurs qu au fond sur le reste de la
société il ya un autre sujet sur lequel
vous allez pouvoir développer vos thèmes
c'est sur l'écologie et sur ce qu'ils
passent à notre dame des landes c'est
mardi
c'est une petite phrase qui a été signé
par jean marie le guen le ministre en
charge des relations avec le parlement
ça se passait lors des questions
d'actualité au sénat
mais si on comprend bien les travaux de
notre dame des landes vont pouvoir
commencer
je peux vous le dire l'automne prochain
sera le moment décisif pour l'engagement
effectif des travaux
je suis heureux de vous apporter cette
information ou plus exactement de vous
l'a confirmé toutes les procédures
nécessaires ont été mises en oeuvre et
l'ensemble des conditions seront
satisfaites
donc visiblement on a bien compris plus
de doute les travaux vont pouvoir
commencer qu'est ce que vous allez faire
mais ça c'est plus de doute pour jean
marc et le web j aime aussi la provoquer
les écologistes
1 il faut savoir que là c'est la
convocation bien sûr bien sûr vous
croyez que y compris sont en train
d'allonger l'état d'urgence on va
mobiliser 3 4000 gardes mobiles pour à
l'évacuer des familles qui sont là
depuis plusieurs générations
des paysans qui travaillent la terre
bien sûr si le roi en dernier donc si
vous avez vu vous avez vu jean marie le
guen
ils sont là mais j'ai provoqué les verts
ils aiment ça ils aiment ça vous savez
il ya un truc est totalement fou ce
projet là au fond plus personne n'y
croit vraiment chez les promoteurs
parce qu'ils voient bien à la fois le
que le tout des pronostics sur
l'explosion du trafic et rien ne se
réalise pas ils voient bien qu'ils aient
un aéroport à nantes atlantique qui
existe déjà
on n'est pas en train de créer un
aéroport dans une zone où il n'y a pas
d'aéroport il ya déjà un aéroport élus
aéroport européen de l'année 2011 est ce
que vous allez faire donc mais moi
j'entends vous il annoncé j'entends
aussi ségolène royal qui dit mais il
n'est pas question d'évacuer à la barre
dame des landes par la force ennemie par
la force
j'entends qu'elle dit enfin il faut
opter faire l'étude indépendante
d'optimisation de l'aéroport actuel
nantes atlantique y compris c'était
l'accord qu'elle était passée entre les
écologistes et les socialistes dans la
perspective du second tour des
régionales donc au fond il ya des
positions de compromis et là il ya une
sorte de réaffirmation de coups de
menton et je rappelle que la france est
toujours
douze infractions européenne le seul
projet en cours parce que c'est ya
effectivement on demande de respecter un
certain nombre de conversions la
commission européenne avait mis en
demeure la france considérait qu'il y
avait une infraction au droit européen
il y as discussions entre l'état
français et la commission européenne
pour refaire le projet notamment l'étude
d'impact sur l'environnement
ce processus n'est pas terminé donc j'en
sais rien vous savez que la crise est
venue pour vous savez que les
évaluations coûts bénéfices sur notre
dame des landes ont été pour le moins
approximative
s'il s'avérait que on a sur dimensionner
les bénéfices de notre dame des landes
et ben même du point de vue de la
commission européenne il y aurait un
problème sur les aides d'état l'accord
sur les aides d'état donc au fond tout
ça est en cours il y à des recours et je
moi quand j'entends un premier ministre
qui considère que les procédures d'appel
ne relève pas des recours juridiques je
suis sidéré qu'un premier ministre on
voit bien qu'il a quelques soucis avec
le pouvoir judiciaire mais qui considère
qu'un appel n'est pas un recours mais
moi j'ai été espionnée par edf
j'ai gagné plein pot en première
instance à nanterre
edf a été condamné au maximum pour
espionnage de greenpeace et de ma
personne eh ben on appelle j'ai perdu
dont je sais y compris à mes dépens
qu'un appel peuvent faire une décision
très différente de la première instance
doit passer à un tout autre sujet de ces
la loi contre le terrorisme qui est
examiné au sénat c'est une proposition
de loi qui émane de la droite et il
souhaite être entendue évidemment dans
ce vaste discussion autour de la réforme
constitutionnelle roi tout en détail le
délit de consultation de sites
terroristes
l installation par des experts de
mouchards sur les ordinateurs de
suspects le sénat à majorité de droite a
voté ce soir les premières dispositions
d'un texte qui vise à étendre l'arsenal
sécuritaire contre le terrorisme
pour sa première intervention en tant
que ministre de la justice jean jacques
urvoas et montrer à l écoute des
sénateurs votre démarche d'ouverture
répond mon pragmatisme
je connais la souveraineté du parlement
le parlement vote les textes telle
qu'ils les jugent pertinent le
gouvernement d'ailleurs se garde bien
puis le début des débats de donner des
avis de fermeture
le texte des sénateurs qui prévoit aussi
les perquisitions de nuit et un régime
d'application des peines plus strictes
devra franchir l'obstacle de l'assemblée
nationale une assemblée à majorité de
gauche qui examinera d'abord le texte du
gouvernement
ce dernier entend adopter le droit à la
lutte antiterroriste il sera présenté
demain en conseil des ministres le texte
des sénateurs il ya le texte a été
présenté en conseil des ministres est ce
que nos tout cela vous voyez une
atteinte aux libertés individuelles
il ya incontestablement une
multiplication de loi de dérogation qui
donne plus de pouvoirs à la police et
moins de pouvoirs aux juges et je suis
très surpris quand on voit quand même
que lé premier président de la cour de
cassation qui sont vraiment pas des gens
qui souhaitent intervenir dans le débat
public
dire qu'il veut lever la voix cette
semaine dire qu'ils sont extrêmement
inquiet de toutes ces évolutions
législatives qui consiste au fond à
favoriser toutes les pertes isa si les
perquisitions
les assignations à résidence tout ça
quand j'entends jacques toubon qui n'est
pas un homme de gauche qui est un
républicain qui n'est pas un homme de
gauche le défenseur des droits
s'inquiéter de toutes ces évolutions
législatives
je me dis que là il ya un dérapage et
quand j'entends le garde des sceaux
jouer
le ministre de l'intérieur bis je trouve
ça dangereux il devrait être celui qui
dit attention il faut laisser le
judiciaire
la démo canon là très clairement il dit
allez-y renforcer le pouvoir sécuritaire
à l'est vers la police et ce qu'il a
fait quand même très largement en tant
que député moi je suis inquiet d'un
garde des sceaux qui ne défend pas le
pouvoir judiciaire et qui au fond défend
une forme de de fuite en avant
législatives qui veulent en permanence
envoyer des signaux à l'opinion publique
comme quoi on veut s'occuper de leur
sécurité mais qui ne répondent pas à
l'enjeu de la sécurité
il ne répond pas l'enjeu ne sera pas
garder faut pour vous il n'y a pas assez
de contrôles et en plus ça ne répond pas
on le voit moi j'aimerais
un des sceaux qui soit en ce moment en
train de faire le tour des capitales
européennes pour qu'il y ait un parquet
européen
ça c'est un enjeu essentiel on le voit
dans toutes les enquêtes sur le
terrorisme
le fait qu'ils aient concurrence ou non
coordination entre les parquets
nationaux c'est une absurdité saccagé
des terroristes peut-être mais bien sûr
ça fait ça fait le jeu des terroristes
en tout cas le fait qu' on n'est pas on
renforce pas plus rapidement les
pouvoirs du renseignement les moyens
humains du renseignement ont fait sur la
police
on le fait pas sur la justice écouté le
juge trévidic qui dit à quel point on
fait pas assez d'efforts en matière de
justice pour pouvoir dans quelles
obligations de l'état d'urgence vous
êtes pour ou contre moi je suis contre
aujourd'hui je trouve qu'au fond encore
une fois l'idée qu'on installe un état
d'exception y compris quand on entend ce
certaines déclarations du premier
ministre sur la bbc en train de dire au
fond sera dans l'état d'exception tant
qu'on n'aura pas éradiquer le terrorisme
c'est une absurdité ça voudrait dire
qu'on sera a dit à mme aeternam
et c'est jamais sain pour une démocratie
au fond que le pouvoir judiciaire soit
mis de côté que les droits soient à
attaquer encore une fois c'est une
équipe est là mais fabrice d'utérus
c'est inefficace du point du littoral
c'est ça le problème à parler d'elle se
trompe de cible
alors on va parler dans une autre mesure
qui fait beaucoup de qui crée beaucoup
de polémiques la déchéance pour tous on
en parle à mercredi
énième coup de théâtre et nm version de
l'article 2 qui figurera dans le projet
de loi constitutionnelle on ne parle
plus de binationaux mais de déchéance de
nationalité pour tous les terroristes la
main du seigneur continue de diviser
françois moulin le texte proposera qu'un
français quel qu'il soit condamné pour
terrorisme pourra être déchu de sa
nationalité par un juge après de
multiples rebondissements
le gouvernement s'est finalement aligné
sur la demande du groupe socialiste à
l'assemblée
il y avait des termes qui suscitait des
réactions disproportionnées
c'était deux termes binationalité et
apatrides y est donc moi je souhaitais
que l'on ne retrouve plus ni dans la
constitution ni dans les textes
d'application les deux termes moi je ne
cherche pas d'accord pour rassembler
uniquement les socialistes je pense que
nous ne serions pas à la hauteur du
moment
si nous ne réussissions pas une majorité
très large et notamment donc la majorité
de gauche et la majorité de droite
une nouvelle rédaction qui devrait
permettre d'obtenir une majorité
socialiste même s'il reste quelques
mécontents
qu'est ce que c'est que cette confusion
qu'est ce que c'est que cette cacophonie
qu'est ce que c'est que ce cirque
vous avez une mesure qui divise la
représentation nation profondément
l'adhésion de l'opposition s'annonce
également des plus incertaines la ligne
officielle celle du président nicolas
sarkozy n'a pas bougé un vote en faveur
du projet initial de françois hollande
devant le congrès le 7 novembre - la
cohérence
c'est la déchéance de la nationalité
pour les terroristes binationaux c'est
ça la cohérence j'ai toujours défendu
cette ligne nous sommes engagés dans un
combat contre l'état islamique
il faut être cohérent il faut arrêter
avec les jeux politiciens
c'est ça la cohérence aujourd'hui
malheureusement le gouvernement s'en
éloigne forcément une autre ligne de
fracture traverse le principal parti
d'opposition le rejet total de l'idée de
déchéance françois fillon nathalie
kosciusko morizet et d'autres
parlementaires
ils sont opposés les discussions
commencent vendredi pour un vote le 10
février
voilà alors vous quelle est votre
position qui est un imbroglio un casse
tête avec des versions qui échangent en
permanence
est ce que cette dernière mouture est la
bonne et ce qu'elle va permettre au
gouvernement de présenter un texte qui a
des chances d'être acceptée que ce que
les recherches n'ont enfin c'est une
histoire de fou cette affaire il ya au
départ on y quand même ça fait des
semaines et des semaines que ce débat
est omniprésent j'entends ce pti mais
personne ne dit qu'une telle mesure
notamment la déchéance de nationalité
arrêtera un quelconque théorie ce dont
personne ne prétend que ça aide à lutter
contre le terrorisme que ça empêchera un
attentat donc on met la question du
terrorisme de côté on a un coût
politique du président françois hollande
qui le jour de son discours au congrès
se dit tiens j'ai pas mal hein je vais
prendre un truc qui a dit nicolas
sarkozy dans un discours à grenoble
qu'il avait lui-même récupéré d'extrême
droite et je vais faire un super coup
j'ai fracturé la droite avec ça ça
marche trois semaines incontestablement
pendant trois semaines la droite serait
droite se divise sur les mains ah bah
oui parce que moi aujourd'hui c'est la
gauche qui cote elle qui complètement
fracturé sur la situation et tout le
monde réfléchit à essayer de trouver une
porte de sortie un mauvais coup
politique et c'est totalement dingue
c'est à dire qu'au fond là vous rendez
compte qu'un gouvernement élu par la
gauche les écologistes est en train
d'interpréter la déclaration universelle
des droits de l'homme pour savoir si
finalement l'apatridie qui seraient
potentiellement utilisé c'est totalement
fou pour croyez que la réforme de la
constitution ira à l'échec où ça
pourrait réussir à mais moi je pense que
la glissade va continuer oui c'est à
dire que personne ne va comprendre quoi
que ce soit mais ce qui est sûr ce ne
sera pas votée j'en sais rien ce qu'ils
peuvent trouver comme compromis parce
qu'au fond on voit bien qu'il ya une
alliance objective là entre hollande et
sarkozy
ils ont topé sur cette histoire là parce
qu'au fond ils veulent se retrouver tous
les deux au premier tour de la
présidentielle
donc ils ont un intérêt objectif à être
tous les deux à se renforcer dans
l'autre pour être tous les deux au
premier tour de la présidentielle mais
ce que je crois c'est qu'on est en train
de glisser de plus en plus ce qu'on fait
ddd des figures artistiques d'un mauvais
de mauvaises de mauvais patinage
artistique au fond pour essayer de
trouver une sortie dans cette affaire
moi je trouve ça totalement affligeant
il faut sortir de cette réforme il faut
avoir le courage mais ce qui est
terrible c'est que la vème république
dit qu aujourd'hui au fond plus le
président a semblé hésitants vous
souvenez qu'avant noël ça paraissait
acquis que il y aurait plus à des
changes il est revenue et maintenant
fond il en fait une affaire personnelle
qui est de dire regardez je suis ferme
tout ça est totalement verte singles et
tout ça est localement sabré leurs ébats
le débat a commencé vendredi on va y
revenir un petit peu plus tard la
voudrais vous parler d'une situation qui
est celle de calais me connaissent
évidemment parker la crise qui a lieu en
ce moment dans cette ville de calais
vous allez voir ce qui s'est passé cette
semaine une réunion très importante
entre les mises la justice ministre de
l'intérieur et les élus locaux regarder
ce contrôle lui il est signé pauline dam
des guides à ne défilera pas dans les
rues de calais la manifestation du
mouvement islamophobe était prévu samedi
le ministre de l'intérieur est le
nouveau garde des sceaux en ont décidé
autrement
j'ai demandé à la préfète du pas de
calais de procédé à l'interdiction de
toutes les manifestations quelles que
soient leurs organisateurs qui sont
susceptibles d'occasionner les troubles
à l'ordre public
de telle sorte à éviter dans cette ville
des affrontements qui n'ont pas lieu
d'être dans la ville n'ont pas besoin
n'a pas besoin
à rassurer des élus en quête de fermeté
il y a deux semaines
une manifestation pro migrants avaient
débouché sur l'occupation d'un ferry par
des migrants et militants
altermondialistes un tour de vis
sécuritaire salué par natacha bouchart
mais la maire de calais veut aller
encore plus loin
parallèlement j'ai demandé l'armée savez
que c'est une demande qui n'est toujours
pas satisfaite
selon bernard cazeneuve l'interdiction
de manifestation durera aussi longtemps
que le climat tensions actuelles
demeurent à deux questions l'une tout
d'abord sur ces interdictions de
manifestations et notamment
ils s'en sont pris au no borders nos
vendeurs c'est une franche
d'associations ou sait pas très bien qui
pousse un petit peu les les migros a à
faire des choses qui paie 10 sites vous
les soutenez c'est no borders
moi je soutiens les migrants de calais
vrai mais les no borders si vous voulez
qu'ils aient des associations un moment
peut-être parfois il les pousse au delà
de ce que voudrait faire les migrants en
même temps c'est aussi une association
qui rappellent en permanence que c'est
totalement dingue de maintenir des gens
dans cette situation la sécu est un
petit peu quand même
non mais je soutiens dans la le fait qu'
ils font vivre ce débat là parce qu'au
fond on aimerait bien oublier ce qui se
passe à calais on aimerait bien qu'ils
vivent dans des conditions abominables
et qu'au fond personne ne voit ce qu'il
nous dit pas ce qui se passe à calais
parce que les est là pour nous le
rappeler que ce soit natacha bouchart ou
xavier bertrand oui mais souvent sur un
mode on veut se débarrasser de ses
migrants est pas on veut résoudre le
problème des migrants de calais on sait
bien que si on n'a pas un moment un
accord avec la grande bretagne sur la
question de calais on s'en sortira pas
pour l'instant il n'est pas la star
forcément c'est totalement dingue qu'il
est jeune et c'est totalement dingue qui
est des enfants des jeunes des mineurs
vous déplaira l'air qu'est-ce que vous
comment vous pouvez influencer le débat
comment vous pouvez tendre le bras des
anglais mais tordre le bras des anglais
c'est un moment vous voyez bien la
négociation mais j'ai finir sur le trône
on a quand même des mineurs à calais qui
aimerait bien rejoindre leur famille en
grande bretagne s'est totalement dingue
d'empêcher ça et ça commence d'ailleurs
la mobilisation commence à se développer
en grande bretagne pour dire
faut régler ce problème de gens qui
veulent aller en grande bretagne ils
retrouvaient leurs familles avoir une
perspective on peut pas être dans un
système européen
on se bat au parlement européen la
commission fait des efforts aussi
d'ailleurs la commission rappelle à la
france ses obligations en matière
d'accueil d'accueil dans des conditions
décentes pourquoi ne pas migrants ont
pris ce qu'ils veulent en ce moment mais
je suis d'accord mais moi moi vous savez
dans ce débat avec les briques dans ce
débat sur l'europe avec les britanniques
il ya un moment il va falloir arrêter de
détricoter l'union européenne parce que
plus on détricote l'union européenne et
moelle est en capacité de répondre au
problème et plus on trouve que l'europe
fait pas son boulot sur la question des
migrants
moi quand j'entends des responsables
politiques attaquer l'europe
je suis sidéré la commission européenne
elle essaye de définir un partage
équitable des réfugiés nous avons une
obligation d'accueillir ces réfugiés ces
réfugiés ne viennent pas pour perturber
nos vies ils viennent parce que leur vie
est fracassé les adore qu'on a il faut
se répartir donc l'union européenne
essaye de faire les choses mais c'est le
national c'est là qu'on voit l'absurdité
des égoïsmes nationaux parce que chacun
sait comme sur la déchéance au fond
chacun essayait de renvoyer à l'autre la
responsabilité si on n'a pas une
responsabilité collective
ça ne marchera jamais on finira par
tirer sur des gens qui rompt s'accrocha
des barbelés c'est fou la zone message
et on revient effectivement à
l'assemblée puisque mercredi toujours
était également à l'ordre du jour une
proposition de loi pour lutter contre la
prostitution
les clients des prostituées seront
désormais sanctionnés d'une
contravention de 1500 euros en cas
d'achat d'actes sexuels la mesure figure
donc dans cette proposition de loi est
ce que c'est la bonne réponse yannick
jadot face à des réseaux qui n'ont peur
de rien d'une prostitution qui se
déplace aussi sur internet 1
il ya dans la prostitution lui quand
même une extrême minorité de femmes qui
ont fait ce choix
le reste c'est de l'abattage c'est de la
marchandisation et c'est de
l'exploitation donc il faut lutter
conseil moisissures le texte
moi j'ai jamais été pour la pénalisation
ni des prostituées ni des clients parce
que je pense que ça peut pas sur un
problème est une pratique qui existe
on dit que c'est le plus vieux métier du
monde qui existe depuis tellement
longtemps je ne pense pas que la
pénalisation soit la réponse parce qu'au
fond on sort de plus en plus de l'espace
semi public
une pratique qui va aller dans des coins
encore plus indécent encore plus dur
pour exercer donc il faut aller
probablement à la rencontre et puis il
faut taper les réseaux chez eux on a
quoi on a quinze inquiète heures en
france qui vont qui se battre contre les
réseaux de prostitution
ça n'est pas là à la hauteur des choses
on sait à quel point à des réseaux ils
vivent ces réseaux devant tout le monde
au vu et au su de tout le monde si je
veux pas croire qu'on peut pas mieux
combattre ces réseaux c'est eux qu'il
faut cartonner ce qu'il faut sanctionner
très lourdement mais avec plus de moyens
humains comme sur la question du
terrorisme a passé au jeudi et
l'assemblée nationale qui se penche sur
la crise agricole
c'est une proposition de loi qui émane
du sénat elle vise à rendre un peu plus
de compétitivité aux agriculteurs le
ministre ses fans le foll jarrousse
avait en ce moment une grave crise dans
le monde agricole c'est le détail de ses
propositions avec astrid de vilaine
cela fait des mois de la quille
cette semaine encore les agriculteurs
ont protesté un peu partout en france
ils dénoncent l'effondrement des cours
qui ne leur permet plus de faire face à
leurs coûts de production
mardi matin françois hollande a reçu à
l'elysée les principaux syndicats
agricoles il réclame des mesures
structurelles
j'ai demandé au chef de l'état
aujourd'hui que pour les agriculteurs
qui n'ont pas accès au cic e.on est un
dispositif alternatif qui permet aussi
une baisse des charges qui pèsent
notamment sur les cotisations sociales
dans l'hémicycle le ministre de
l'agriculture défend sa politique
si aujourd'hui dans l'aviculture ont
dépassé 1 vers galles vers 8 milliards
d'euros de baisses de charges c'est
parce que a été pris on était pris des
décisions par cette majorité pour faire
bénéficier de l'agriculture les baisses
de charges et le pack de responsabilité
alors que la crise s'éternise les
républicains ont tenu mercredi une
réunion de travail sur le sujet nicolas
sarkozy plaide pour un plan marshall à
10 milliards d'euros
dans ce plan nous affichons un premier
principe c'est le principe de parité 1
euro investi dans la ville doit
correspondre à un euro investi dans nos
campagnes
une proposition de loi des républicains
pour la compétitivité des filières sera
étudiée ce matin à l'assemblée
les agriculteurs ont prévu de poursuivre
leur action
certains allant jusqu'à menacer de
boycotter le salon de l'agriculture
dans un mois à paris question assez
simple dans le contexte actuel de
concurrence de compétitivité ce qu'on
peut se permettre aujourd'hui de garder
une forme d'agriculture spécificité
française du quel point de vue
spécificités puisqu'on aime forme
d'agriculture aujourd'hui qui est
différent de ce que font les autres pays
européens
quand on voit l'espagne aujourd'hui
qu'il ya une exception française
il y a en partie une exception française
vous avez mais on retrouve ça dans tous
les pays européens
vous avez une agriculture qui veut
défendez territoire valoriser les
terroirs pour une partie de
l'agriculture et celle là à coups de
chaîne non non non celle-là ne manifeste
pas et cela ne touche quasiment aucune
subvention
ceux qui font les labels ceux qui font
de la qualité ceux qui s'orientent vers
les marchés locaux il touche a pas un
euro du plan le foie donc ce qui me dis
cela ce qui touchait sur les substances
bien sûr et moi quand je vois xavier
beulin patron de la fnsea grand'pa trop
de l'agroalimentaire c'est ces gens là
qui disent l'avenir qui ont dit aux
agriculteurs endettés vous endettez vous
l'avenir c'est le marché mondial c'est
la chine c'est la russie et on nous
sommes nous espérons être compétitif
avec les brésiliens
c'est eux qui ont cassé tous les outils
de contrôle de la position dentaire non
ce sont en fait ils ont le double
discours permanent si vous voulez xavier
beulin a encore une fois il a poussé
l'agriculture et ses prédécesseurs
pareil quand ils sont à bruxelles ils
disent lâcher complètement les quotas de
production on avait bien sûr on avait
des quotas de production en matière
laitière ça marche et il y avait des
revenus mais quelques uns se sont dit
moi je vais tuer les petits je vais
m'agrandir je vais produire énormément
et j'ai exporterait comme on fait les
céréaliers sauf que quand vous exportez
comme ça un moment vous êtes dans la
surproduction les prix s'écroulent et
vous dites on veut plus de normes
environnementales
on veut plus de cotisations sociales
parce qu'évidemment vous serez jamais
compétitif avec les brésiliens et les
autres là où faut faire et c'est dommage
que le plan le foll soutiennent toujours
cette concentration cette vision du
marché mondial qui est totalement folle
mettons l'argent dans par exemple la
restauration collective
on pourrait avoir des débouchés
extraordinaire pour l'agriculture pour
son respect de l'environnement maintien
des paysans parce que c'est un plan
social extraordinaire l'agriculture
c'est des milliers de paysans qui
disparaissent tous les ans et allons
vers une alimentation de qualité au
niveau local c'est ça qu'il faut faire
quand nicolas sarkozy parle de 10
milliards d'euros pour l'agriculture
c'est ce que touche la france tous les
ans de la pac qu'est ce qu'on fait de
cet argent on le donne d'abord aux
céréaliers car on le donne très peu aux
éleveurs et on leur dit l'agriculture
mondiale
c'est totalement fou et dernière chose
xavier beulin il est quand il est arrivé
il avait dit on va faire la péréquation
entre les céréaliers et les éleveurs où
est la solidarité des céréaliers avec
les éleveurs et ben merci on va quitter
ce terrain à l'école pour revenir des
sujets régaliens puisque vendredi ça y
est manuel valls a donné le coup d'envoi
de la révision constitutionnelle à
l'assemblée le projet doit de protection
de la nation comprend deux articles il
constitutionnalise l'état d'urgence et
un article sur la déchéance de
nationalité 200 amendements ont été
déposés le premier ministre est en
première ligne pour défendre ce texte
écouté par respect pour la parole donnée
devant la représentation nationale par
le chef de l'état trois jours après ces
attentats
par respect pour les français leur
courage
cette impressionnante force de caractère
qu'ils ont démontrée doivent être pour
nous un commandement une injonction à
nous rassembler et quoi de mieux que
notre texte constitutionnel le socle
même de notre démocratie pour le faire
face à la menace
face à toutes ces déchirures de notre
société et je pense aux actes
antisémites anti musulmans anti
chrétiens face aux risques de tension de
divisions nous devons être forts donc
unie face à la menace
face aux actes de guerre parce que nous
sommes en guerre
le vote est prévu mercredi prochain sur
ce texte que vous pensez que le débat
ira jusqu'au bout ont parlé de
cacophonie là on a attribué ce qui
explique rabah là ils instrumentalisent
totalement l'état de sidération de la
société évidemment pendant les attentats
et ap les attentats pour dire il faut
être unis pour diviser les français
c'est quand même un drôle d'une drôle de
mécanique politique je veux dire et
c'est quand même à la fois un déchéance
de nationalité
les terroristes s'en foutent
complètement ça tous les experts le
disent en revanche effectivement des
binationaux il y en a 27 qui ont été
tués pendant les attentats
le 13 novembre donc ça peut pas on peut
pas en faire des suspects alors qu'ils
ont été les victimes
et c'est pas un hasard si une telle
proportion de binationaux qui ont été
ciblés par les terroristes parce qu'au
fond
il exprime l'ouverture de la société et
donc vouloir revenir sur le droit du sol
ou vouloir diviser les français selon
leur statut à travers
l'instrumentalisation électorale 2 de la
constitution c'est une terrible faute
parce que manuel valls vous dise c'est
unité nationale c'est à dire que oui non
mais m'ont d'ailleurs il serait bien
dommage moi j'en ai ras-le-bol
j'en ai ras-le-bol de cons qu'on essaie
de construire l'unité nationale sur la
peur et sur les victimes des attentats
il va nous faire l'unité nationale sur
le terroriste jusqu'au premier tour de
la présidentielle c'est irrespectueux
mentalisation c'est une
instrumentalisation c'est irrespectueux
des victimes des attentats
et c'est une instrumentalisation
politicienne qui au fond est en train de
diviser les français
diviser son camp mais bien au delà de
son camp parce qu'il ya des gens
extrêmement important à droite qui
trouve aussi que c'est une
instrumentalisation
on ne touche pas à la loi suprême pour
réussir une échéance électorale sur le
sérieux sont le fond sur la déchéance de
nationalité sur l'article de écouter ce
que disent encore manuel valls
nous touchons avec la déchéance de la
nationalité et nous avons entendu le
débat public
l'avis des juristes et intellectuels à
un élément essentiel de la personne la
sanction proposée est grave et nous
oblige à regarder loin à ne pas
seulement considérer les quelques jours
qui viennent mais sans doute je disais
tout à l'heure
la décennie qui s'annonce cet amendement
inscrit donc au coeur de la constitution
le principe d'égalité de tous devant
l'exigence républicaine
voilà ce qu'a dit manuel valls sur cet
article 2 est ce que je voudrais vous
soumettre c'est ce qu'a répondu cécile
duflot un petit peu plus tard après
cette allocution vichy c'est le dernier
régime à avoir utilisé massivement la
déchéance
manuel valls a reproché à cécile duflot
cette utilisation du mot vichy et cécile
duflot a continué en disant la gauche a
jeté aux oubliettes
nos valeurs notre réaction la plupart
des pays qui ont été victimes des
attentats n'ont jamais utilisé ni l'état
d'urgence ni ce type de mesures vichy
c'est un monde parallèle c'est pas je
sais pas c'est lé symbole mais au fond
le problème c'est que il ya une telle
mise en scène du discours par manuel
valls qu'un moment au fond il faut aussi
casser cette truc où on nous prend pour
sa partie où on nous rappelle en
permanence les victimes
moi j'habite rue bichat donc je sais mes
gamins étaient dehors le soir des
attentats dans ce quartier où il ya eu
des massacres mais en permanence
utiliser ça encore une fois pour pour
jouer et là on nous fait ça d'une
manière tellement péremptoire forte mais
roger a rejeté mardi le le le même
manuel valls disait avant noël aux
journalistes il faut revenir sur la
déchéance de nationalité personne n'a
compris quand il dit qu'ils consultent
les intellectuels donnez moi un seul
intellectuel qui défend la déchéance de
nationalité
patrick weil qui est un peu une
référence je dire il est il et il n'en
revient pas de cette incompétence de 7
environ est majorité parlementaire de
gauche pour noter cette année
jugeant j'en sais rien ce qui sera la
fin jura on est dans un tel
improvisation je ne sais pas ce qui sera
la fin ce que je vois c'est que là on
nous fait un discours martial pour
essayer de remettre tout le monde dans
l'ordre en me disant ne voulons pas
diviser les français mais ce qu'il fait
tous les jours s'est divisée merci alors
on passe tout de suite à la suite de
l'actualité politique à votre actualité
notamment est notre partenaire nous
rejoint la langue du scan s'est tout de
suite
jaime jara c'est bonjour c'est avons
peut-être ça bouge en hôtel mont joli
nick shadow
bonjour alors on le sait vous êtes l'un
des signataires de l'appel pour une
primaire à gauche qui a fait l'objet de
vives discussions encore cette semaine
on a l'impression que chaque camp on
essaye de reporter la responsabilité
d'un échec sur sur l'autre françois
hollande par la voix de cambadélis se
dit prêt à y aller mais seulement si
jean luc mélenchon eva lequel dit pas
question d'y aller puisque pas question
de soutenir hollande si jamais il gagne
c'est que ça a l'air d'être assez mal
embarquée quand même en plus que c'est
difficile c'est difficile mais est ce
que finalement si mélenchon et hollande
sont pas d'accord avec le fait que la
gauche et les écologistes que les
citoyennes et les citoyens se
réapproprient la politique qu'ils aient
pas envie d'aller au crash démocratique
en 2017 et d'être contraint comme ça
s'est passé en paca ailleurs de voter
pour un candidat de droite pour éviter
l'extrême droite
qu'est ce qu'on fait on s'arrête de
penser on considère que françois
hollande est candidat naturel d'un droit
naturel comme y avait il ya deux siècles
un droit divin que françois hollande ne
peux pas alors qu'ils pensent matin midi
et soir l'élection présidentielle qui
nous a fait le coup de la déchéance et
de la réforme constitutionnelle pour
l'élection présidentielle
il pourrait pas participer à trois
débats ils ne pourraient pas venir
expliquer qu est ce qu il a fait de son
quinquennat alors que son camp pour le
moins est perturbée confus un peu
déstabilisés par rapport aux promesses
de 2012 et que mélenchon lui se voit
comme le candidat incarnant le peuple
alexandre est indispensable à ces deux
personnalités politiques dans cette non
course
la présence des forces politiques de
gauche et écologique saissac
indispensable moi je me refuse à ce que
la politique soit aujourd'hui accaparé
qu'on soit tous l'otage des ego ou des
ambitions des unes et des 1
je pense qu'aujourd'hui on a besoin
notre primaire c'est un ballon d'oxygène
dans la politique française
on voit un camp qui est totalement
assommé qui est totalement à 6 et donc a
besoin qu on ouvre les portes qu'à
besoin qu'on ouvrait ce maître qu'a
besoin de débattre franchement est-ce
qu'il faut pas débattre aujourd'hui à
gauche sur le chômage sur tous les
sujets dont on a parlé aujourd'hui
justement compris à des différences
d'appréciation au sein des différentes
sensibilités de gauche écologistes donc
c'est sain
il faut discuter et puis lyon ce
processus démocratique dont on connaît
pas la fin ces savants des percées sur
ces questions d'idées dont vous parlez
la question du chômage
qui dit candidature commune dit
programme commun comment aujourd'hui on
peut considérer que la gauche puisse
avoir un programme commun allant de
jean-luc mélenchon à emmanuel macron est
ce que c'est possible
moi je veux des idées je me fous
aujourd'hui d'aider des personnes qui
pensent avoir un destin présidentiel
gelant les idées justement le programme
est bien mais lyon nous non je ne dis
pas que c'est facile mais est ce que on
gère pas y compris dans ses différentes
sensibilités des villes est-ce qu'on
gère pas des régions est-ce que nous
sommes définitivement irréconciliables
tous les bruxellois ya un pardon a
surtout l'impression vous occuper le
terrain autre cas c'est une tentative
c'est une tentative que les
sympathisants de gauche écologistes que
les électeurs de gauche écologie se
réapproprie l'élection présidentielle
parce qu'aujourd'hui au fond tout le
monde est résigné potentiellement à ce
que ce soit sarkozy le pen au second
tour ce qui serait une catastrophe pour
ce pays selon moi et pour une
déflagration énorme preuve vous rendez
compte on a tous été surpris quand même
un peu en 2002 le fait que la gauche
soit pas au 2e tour et que ce soit le
front national là on a l'impression
qu'on est en train de s'y résigner il ya
six semaines après les élections
régionales
sur ce plateau est sûr de tout le monde
disait faut tout changer et maintenant
faut plus rien changer il faut y aller
au massacre comme ça en centimes pendant
l'année dernière question sur la
question la primaire vous avez annoncé
que vous souhaitez organiser le scrutin
le même jour que les huit maires de
droite ça veut dire c'est beaucoup moins
d'eau à lavau passionnés
honnêtement ça faire ça ça va pas ça va
pas vous passionnez une que c'est cette
respiration démocratique à droite et qui
en même temps cette respiration
démocratique à gombe novembre 2016 voire
il veut dire une campagne qui
commencerait au début
à la fin de l'été quelque chose comme ça
cela ferait en gros huit mois de
campagne jusqu'à laquelle à l'élection
présidentielle est ce que c'est possible
et en présidant à droite à droite quand
la date limite de dépôt des candidatures
à voir c'est quand c'est septembre
septembre c'est en septembre on peut
faire exactement l'amour à goiânia
septembre musical avec son président
mais ça hein ça empêche pas d'agir
d'accord jeudi ont parlé de la crise
agricole on peut parler du show grèce
2-1 2-2 ça n'empêche pas d'agir mais on
sait que l'obsession c'est la
présidentielle donc à partir du moment
où de toute façon en à l'automne
l'obsession sera l'élection
présidentielle il va y avoir le camp de
droite qui va y compris peut-être
s'engueuler confronté marqué leurs
divergences mais tout le monde sait que
les français en ont envie et tout le
monde s'extasie mobile et il doit avoir
un chef de l'état s'engueuler avec ses
partenaires
mais les français ont peut-être il vous
a pas échappé que 80 % de l'électorat de
gauche et de l'électorat français
d'ailleurs ne voulons ni de nicolas
sarkozy ni de françois hollande ni de
marine le pen
les français ils ont envie de débat est
ce que vous trouvez normal que le
dernier débat au fond ça a été en 2012
et qu'au fond le président de la
république qui pour le moins c'est un
peu écarté des promesses qu'il a faites
pour être élu il n'aurait pas se
justifier vis-à-vis du camp qui l'a élu
et qu'il irait jusqu au mois de mars en
faisant elle est une vraie tuile minutes
si françois hollande ne va pas vous avez
dit qu'il y aurait une candidature
écologiste une sorte de menace qui pour
ti pour la porter cette candidature
s'est il arrêté de penser aux personnes
les gens ils s'en foutent des personnes
qui à un moment il faille incarné dans
une élection présidentielle c'est une
évidence il faut emmener les gens sur un
projet il faut avoir la sincérité et
tout ça mais si vous mettez les
personnes au début de sa tout est mort
donc arrêter si le président la
république ne bouge pas d'ici mars
prochain d'ici avril prochain au fond
oui il y aura des candidatures
écologique puisque même nicolas hulot ne
veut pas rentrer dans ce gouvernement et
donc traduire des algues vertes is your
à mélenchon il y en aura d'autres eh ben
le camp de la gauche ira t il
il est l'humiliation subie naïve ou le
seco ne sont pas au second damien aussi
jamie se présente bien sûr c'est un
excellent candidat
enfin ce sera le mot de la fin merci si
le présent s'il se présente merci à des
cadeaux d'avoir été l'invité de parlons
en donnant par là